AND IT NEVER REALLY IS ALL
THAT CLEAR WHEN MIKE TOMLIN
NEGOTIATING A NEW CONTRACT.
YOU DON'T HEAR MUCH ABOUT IT,
BUT YOU DO HEAR ABOUT IT
DIRECTLY FROM THE TEAM WHEN
THERE'S A NEW DEAL TOMLIN
THREE-YEAR EXTENSION THROUGH
2024 IF HE COACHES OUT THAT
IT WILL MEAN THAT THE SONS,
STEELERS HAVE GONE FIFTY SIX
SEASONS WITH A TOTAL OF THREE
HEAD COACHES UNBELIEVABLE AND
COULD GO ANOTHER 15 20 YEARS
AS COACH OF THE STEELERS.
HE'S ALREADY BEEN ON THE JOB
SINCE 2007. SO I GOT WHO IS
ONE OF THE MORE ACCOMPLISHED
COACHES IN THE NFL? HE'S GOT
EARLY IN HIS TENURE. HE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE THE MAN IN
THEY MIGHT BE THE GREATEST
ORGANIZATION IN THE NFL. IF
NOT ALL OF SPORTS MIKE JUST
THE WAY THEY HANDLE THE
COACHING POSITION. THEY HIRE
SOMEBODY THEY THINKS GOING TO
FAITH IN THEM AND THEY LEAVE
THEM THERE FOR HOWEVER LONG
THEY WANT TO STAY THERE AND
COACHES BEFORE MIKE TOMLIN S
RIGHT? THEY WERE GREAT ME,
COACHES AND MIKE THOMAS DONE
THE SAME THE FACT THAT THE
GUYS NEVER HAD A LOSING
RECORD IS JUST AMAZING TO ME
FOR AS LONG AS HE'S BEEN
THERE 14 YEARS.
NOW NEVER HAD A LOSING RECORD.
IT'S JUST UNBELIEVABLE. BUT
ONLY STEELERS FANS WOULD BE
SOME COMMENTS ON TWITTER. OH
LORD, WE DON'T WANT HIM TO
STAY THAT LONG. WE NEED A NEW
WIN EVERY SINGLE YEAR YOUR
CONTENDER EVERY SINGLE YEAR
BE GRATEFUL THAT MIKE TOMLIN
IS YOUR COACH IF THIS GUY
TIN JOB OFFERS IN THE NFL VE
THIS A POCKET IS STEELERS
FANS THOUGH, AND IT'S NOT
JUST A POCKET. IT'S A SEAM
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE
WHEN THINGS ARE GOING POORLY
THEY IMMEDIATELY START
CLAMORING FOR A NEW COACH AND
I DON'T GET IT. I KNOW THERE
WAS A TIME WHEN SOME OF THE
AND WE'RE TRYING TO GET OUR
THE TEAM TO CHANGE COACHES. S
DIDN'T HAVE CONTROL OF THE IN
TEAM AND ROONEY TO HIS CREDIT
JUST TELLS THEM. OKAY. THANK
YOU POINT TAKE AND YOU HAVE
NO POWER HERE. PLEASE LEAVE
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS I'VE
HEARD FROM OTHER COACHES
ABOUT TOM AND AND LOOK PRO
FOOTBALL COACHES ARE WIRED TO
THINK THEY'RE THE BEST AT
ABUNDANCE OF CONFIDENCE N
BORDERING ON DELUSION. THEY
AREN'T ALL THAT.
GOING TO START THROWING
BOUQUETS AT THEIR COMPETITORS.
I'VE HEARD FROM OTHER HEAD
COACHES. WHAT A GOOD COACH
MIKE TOMLIN IS BECAUSE ONE
THING HE DOES HE FINDS A WAY
TO GET THE ABSOLUTE MOST OUT
OF EVERY PLAYER THAT HE HAS
AND IF IT HAPPENS TO BE A
PLAYER WHO WOULD BE A PROBLEM.
HE KEEPS HIM FROM BEING A
PROBLEM FOR THE MOST PART NOW
WITH ANTONIO BROWN AND
EVENTUALLY BUBBLED OVER BUT
THERE HAVE BEEN OTHER GUYS
WHO IT ISN'T UNTIL THEY GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE. DID THEY
BECOME A PROBLEM AND MIKE
TOMLIN IS ONE OF THE MAIN
REASONS WHY?
THOSE PLAYERS RESPOND TO HIM
WIN FOR HIM AND WHATEVER AND
THEIR TALENT WOULD SUGGEST
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN SINCE
2007. THEY'RE BETTER WINS AND
LOSSES BETTER THAN WHAT THEIR
TALENT OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE
INDICATED IF SOMEONE ELSE HAD
BEEN COACHING THE TEAM.
NO QUESTION, MIKE AND I HAVE
NO NO NO NO
, NO THOUGHTS THAT MIKE
TOMLIN WON'T ACT OUT LAST
CHUCK. NO, I THINK HE'S GOING
TO BE THERE LONGER THAN CHUCK.
ANY DOUBT ABOUT THAT. NO
DOUBT WHATSOEVER ABOUT THAT.
MOLLY QUESTION IS DOES HE WIN
AS MANY CHAMPIONSHIPS AS
CHUCK NOLL DID AND THAT OF
COURSE IS THE BIG QUESTION
AND WE'RE STEELERS FANS. COME
IN AND SAY ALL RIGHT. HE WON
WE'VE BEEN BACK ONCE SINCE
WERE THREE AND SIX IS THE
LAST SUPER
OH APPEARANCE. WE WANT MORE I
GET THAT THEY'RE USED TO
WINNING. ALL THOSE SUPER
THE CHUCK NOLL WAS ABLE TO
WIN AND THEN OBVIOUSLY YOU HAD
BILL COWHER COME IN AND STAY
A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME AND
WHEN ANOTHER ONE THEY WANT
MORE OF THOSE SUPER FOOLS
LIKE GET IT, BUT IT'S ALSO A
DIFFERENT ERA THAN THE 1970S.
TO GET BACK AND YET EVERY RD
SINGLE YEAR. HE HAS THEM IN
POSITION PEOPLE SEEM TO
FORGET LAST YEAR THAT THIS IS
A TEAM TO START AT 11 AND
GO TEAM, BUT THE FACT IS THEY
STARTED ELEVEN AND HOLA
SEASON. WE WERE STILL TALKING
ABOUT THEM POTENTIALLY GOING
TO THE SUPER BOWL AT 11:00
AND OH AND THEY DIDN'T DO IT.
WE KNOW THAT IT WAS
DISAPPOINTING FINISH IN THE
POSTSEASON, BUT THEY'RE
ALWAYS THERE MIKE AND I WILL
BE INTERESTED TO SEE IF MIKE
TALMAN CAN DO WHAT CHUNK NO
DID IN WINNING AS MANY
CHAMPIONSHIPS. I DO THINK
THEY'LL WIN ANOTHER ONE WILL
IT GET TO FOR I DOUBT THAT
IT'S JUST HARDER TO DO NOW,
BUT I DO THINK HE'LL WIN
ANOTHER AT LEAST ONE MORE IN GH
HIS TI